so what are you going to do I think I'm
going to become Christian
[Music]
bro so we're we're just uh comparing
Islam and Christianity seeing why one is
true over the other first of all there's
some added verses in the Bible so are
you saying that added versus addition
and let's say even subtraction things
were removed from the Bible that would
also show like that it's false well show
it needed to be changed so it must have
been something wrong so would that mean
that the religion is false or or no yeah
because what you follow is corrupted but
you would make it false I'd say if
that's your standard for why a religion
is false then I think that you have to
say Islam is false then because there
are verses removed from the Quran have
you heard of uh the verses of of
suckling what makes what makes um a
marriage unlawful I can't remember it
now I got you all right remember his
argument guys is that if there are
verses that are added or taken away from
the text that means that the religion is
false that's his criteria not mine but
let's go with it so this is sa Muslim
14528 it says Aisha reported that it had
been revealed in the Holy Quran that 10
clear sucklings make the marriage
unlawful then it was abrogated and
substituted by five sucklings and
Allah's Apostle died and it was before
that time in the Holy Quran and recited
by the Muslims so we have these verses
of the 10 sucklings that got changed in
the Quran to five sucklings but this
verse about the five sucklings is what
we should at least see in the Quran
still but it's nowhere to be found so
since verses are missing in the Quran
then according to your standard Islam is
false so then when I make both false
according to your standard it would now
I can show you you know I can show you
the difference in Christianity but just
at first I just want to make sure that
you're consistent that this according to
that standard that you set that would
mean that Islam is false right yeah so
then Islam is false now let me show you
that Christ let me show you that
Christianity doesn't have this issue
because we don't have anything missing
we have more than what we need it's not
stuff is added stuff isn't taken away
you have a difference between you know
you have a difference of manuscript
tradition some manuscripts survived more
than others some the later manuscripts
are more put together than the earlier
ones right better survived but that
doesn't mean that we're missing anything
or that things are added we don't we
don't have additions to our text because
we also have oral tradition like from
the church fathers and stuff like that
that have preserved these uh these texts
these scriptures which is why we see we
like we can trace all of our we can
trace our our variance to the New
Testament we could trace our variance to
church fathers who are quoting these
things you know the church fathers are
Disciples of the Disciples of Jes Jesus
you know people who learned under the
disciples and then their disciples and
then so on and so on and so on like so
for example here's here's a a famous one
first John 5:7 right 1 John 5:7 doesn't
appear in our earliest Greek manuscripts
uh that the Father the word and the
spirit these three are one that that
doesn't appear in our earliest Greek
manuscripts but it's in our later
manuscripts so people would say oh well
that that shows an addition no just
because our earlier Greek manuscripts
don't don't have that doesn't mean that
it wasn't there right because we have
early church fathers like cyprian and
other people uh tertullian Who quote
First John 5:7 who appealed to it who
referenced it meaning they had access to
it in their scriptures which validates
the latter manuscripts go ahead where if
it's not in the manuscripts where would
they have got from no it is in the
manuscripts that's what I'm saying it's
in the manuscripts but it just shows up
in the later manuscripts not in the
earliest ones that we have have but that
doesn't mean that it was never there you
right we just we don't have the earlier
manuscripts where that would have
survived right um due to time or
whatever burnings a lot of things taking
place Roman the Romans burning the
scriptures and you know all this stuff
that has taken place we have you know
manuscripts get lost in time however we
do have them in our manuscripts just in
the later
ones the fact that the church Church
fathers the Disciples of the disciples
right who carry the tradition of the
Apostles of Jesus the fact that they are
quoting these references shows that they
had access to
them so it strengthens the evidence for
the latter manuscripts who have for
example 1 John
5:7 you
know you get does that make sense do you
understand what I'm saying
yeah yeah I
get so um Tech textual criticism is what
it's called it's a wide subject it's
something that I'm learning myself um
but these little things I do have a
surface level grasp on you know very
very surface level there's others that
can actually break this down you know to
a te you know way better than I can I
have brothers that can do that for you
so um if you want um I can see if one of
them can come up and we can talk about
that stuff if you're interested if you
have questions about
that yeah I have another question for
you
okay so um you agree Jesus's death was
necessary right I
do uh for what
sins for you said for what
sins yeah like every sin original sin
which one so yeah so original sin is
that
uh that humans are now born with the
inclination of sin we're born with the
urge and nature of sin right so that's
because of what Adam did because Adam
ate the fruit sin entered the world and
now we're all born entered into sin in a
sinful nature he died for the sins that
everyone in the past and the present and
the future have committed so that means
that now whoever believes in the Messiah
even the ones in the past who believed
in the Messiah when the prophets were
told about him and um everyone looked to
him for their salvation they were set
free the people in Jesus's time who came
to believe in him they were set free
from their sin and then people who will
believe in the future like you like me
and others who believe you know our sins
are forgiven as well right so if there
was ways to be forgiven in the Old
Testament before Jesus
came that would mean he technically
didn't have to die right because there
was ways to be forgiven the way to be
forgiven according to the Old Testament
was blood Leviticus 1711 it says that
the atonement of the life is in the
blood without the blood there is no
atonement so then it wasn't necessary if
there was ways to be forgiven it is
necessary but you could get to heaven
without him correct say that again you
could be forgiven like and go to heaven
without him correct or not no you get to
heaven because because of the work of
Christ yeah but you could give s
sacrifices and stuff to be forgiven all
of that was foreshadowing the ultimate
sacrifice that's the point the those
sacrifices were temporary and they did
not fully atone for them right it it
just it covered them temporarily but it
didn't fix them it didn't it didn't wash
them clean or make them pure it's the
blood of Christ that does it
completely so what was the point of
giving sacrifices in
to temporarily atone for themselves
which is why they had to do it every all
the
time
and sorry it was a it was a
foreshadowing of what God was getting
ready to do ultimately all of that stuff
was preparing them for what Christ was
going to come and do and why did he have
to die for the new Cen like Moses didn't
so why why would he have to die for it
Moses could
Moses couldn't atone for our sins
himself he was just a a man no the cant
like I don't know how to pronounce it
sorry
Covenant so what what about the Covenant
what are you asking why why did Jesus
have to die for it if Moses
didn't if Moses
law are you are you asking why did Jesus
have to die for the New Covenant when
Moses didn't have to die for the
Covenant he he had is that what you're
asking yeah
okay because Moses can't he he he his he
can't die for the sins of others he's a
mere man and he's sinful
himself Jesus is the Divine Son of God
who shares the same Essence as the
father who has the power Holiness and
ability to be able to then take on the
sins of the world and crush it destroy
it put an end to it Moses can he's a
mere man who was sinful like you and
me who also needed a savior and had to
offer his own
sacrifices now why is that necessary
because once again according to the law
atonement for sin is through the blood
secondly the Bible says that the price
of sin is death the wages of sin the
price of it is
death right so we couldn't do it
ourselves or we could have you know God
could have just eliminated us and you
know we suffer for our sin but he didn't
want to do that he wanted to save us so
he came the son came took unhuman nature
represented mankind himself and did it
for
us yep that's the gospel you know this
what I was I was about to say you know
this is talked about in the Old
Testament right like the prophets
literally talk about how the Messiah is
going to do this for
us you did you want to you want to see
it yeah man that's all you had to say
man all you had to say was man pull that
out watch this bro have you heard of the
prophet Isaiah yep all right we're going
to go to chapter 53 of his book surely
he has borne our griefs and carried our
sorrows yet we esteemed him stricken
Smitten by God and afflicted
but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities upon him was the chastisement
that brought us peace and with his
wounds we are healed all we like sheep
have gone astray we have turned everyone
to his own way and the lord has laid on
him the iniquity of us
all iniquity is
sin so you see how even in the prophecy
now I could keep reading and going it
gets even better but you see how even
just here it talks about how he's
goingon to be pierced for our
transgressions crushed for our sins the
Lord is going to put on him the sins of
us
all by his punishment that he takes on
it brings us peace his wounds him being
wounded brings us
healing this might sound like a dumb
question but if this was if this was
before why does it say he was pissed
like oh it's not a dumb question brother
that's actually a it's a fair question
it's called the prophetic perfect the
prophetic perfect tense so basically God
when he's giving prophecy um and and and
the prophets talk about the prophecy
they've you know like seen the vision
they got the Revelation it's as if it's
already done they talk as if it already
happened it's called the prophetic
perfect
okay but it's it's the future
tense thank you of course of course but
yeah we have we have stuff like like
even even um even David in the Psalms
and the zabor even he talks about it the
very first verse of this uh Psalms is
what it says my God my God why have you
forsaken me does that sound familiar to
you at all yeah what does it sound like
sat down on the cross exactly
Jesus said this on the
cross but this is David writing this a
thousand years before Jesus is even born
here on
Earth before and and I don't know how
many years before maybe uh I don't I
forget I'm not going to say exactly but
it's a few hundred years before
crucifixion is even invented this is
what this is what David is writing in
the Psalms in the zabor okay my God my
God why have you forsaken me why are you
so far from saving me from the words of
my groaning oh go oh my God I Cry by day
but you do not answer and by night and
by night but I find No Rest yet You Are
Holy enthroned on the Praises of Israel
right let me just skip down a little
bit verse verse six but I am a worm and
not a man scorned by mankind and
despised by the people all who see me
mock me they make mouths at me they wag
their heads he trusts in the Lord let
him deliver him let him rescue him for
he Delights in
him yet you are he who took me from the
womb you made me trust you at my
mother's breast all right let's just
skip down just a little bit
more he says uh verse 14 I am poured out
like water and all my bones are out of
joint my heart is like Wax it is melted
within my
breast my strength is dried up like a PO
like a pot shirt and my tongue sticks to
my jaws you lay me in the dust of death
for dogs Encompass me a company of
evildoers in circles me they have
pierced my hands and my
feet I count all my bones they stare and
gloat over me they divide my garments
among them and for my clothing they cast
lots that's exactly what happens with
Jesus the Roman soldiers they stripped
him of his garments and they gambled
over them they gambled over his cloak
and they pierced his hands and his feet
that's explicitly talking about a
crucifixion isn't it yeah so if we have
this gospel message long before any new
testament is thought of long before
there's a an existence of a Paul of
Tarsus who will come later long before
there is a Peter or a Matthew Mark Luke
or John long before any of these
characters we have the prophet
telling
us that the Messiah is going to be
crucified he's going to have his hands
and his feet pierced David says this
he's going to be pierced for our
transgressions and the Lord is going to
place all of our sins on him Isaiah says
this the prophets are speaking of these
things a thousand years beforehand 700
years beforehand prophesying these
things we can clearly see that God
reveals this so m question I guess to
You Leon would
be why won't you believe what God has
revealed I don't know bro kind of makees
sense now yeah and when we see go ahead
well what what denomination are you cuz
I've heard of the Orthodox Catholic but
I I'm not sure what's basically the
difference um there's little technical
differences between them me myself I'm
not Catholic or Orthodox I by default
fall under protestantism by default I
don't protest the church but that's just
where I fall under you know but but yeah
but they all all all of the these sects
within
Christianity they affirm the father Son
and Holy Spirit they affirm the
salvation by grace through your faith in
Christ Jesus and that your good works
are uh product of your faith and prove
your faith and show that your faith is
true they all affirm the death burial
and resurrection of Jesus Christ came in
the flesh died for our sins rose again
on the third
day they all affirm
this and it's because of stuff like what
I just showed you now here's another
thing so I I showed you the the prophets
now watch what Jesus says
himself Jesus says this himself hold on
let me go
now now we're going to bring out the New
Testament just a few verses in
there mark 45 and then let's do
Luke
22 uh 44 to
46 this is what we'll do here with
this so this is Mark 10:45 Jesus says
for even the son of man came not to be
served but to serve and to give his life
as a ransom for
many Jesus says this is what he came to
do to give his life as a ransom for
many Luke 22
44-46 this is in the
gospel all right um I'm sorry Luke 24 my
bad Luke
24 then he said to them these are my
words that I spoke to you while I was
still with you that everything written
about me in the law in the law of Moses
the Torah and the prophets and the
Psalms must be
fulfilled then he opened their minds to
understand the scriptures and said to
them thus it is written that the Christ
should suffer and on the third day rise
from the
dead so even Jesus says all of this was
already
foretold my suffering was already
foretold and I told you guys about this
when I was with you the prophets told
you guys about this I told you about
this this is the continuity of the
message one message all throughout the
Torah the prophets the Psalms all the
way to the gospel the Messiah is going
to redeem Mankind from from their sins
through his suffering
sacrifice so if we have all of this we
have all the prophets that agree we have
the Messiah that affirms this the
apostles that affirm
this and then we have Muhammad who comes
600 years after Jesus that says no this
didn't happen no it was just made to
appear people thought it was but Allah
saved him
instead disagreeing and contradicting
the other prophets who would you go with
all the prophets and the Messiah that
agree with each other that have the same
message or would you go with the one who
claims a prophet who contradicts
them who would you go with if you're
being
honest
prophets so what are you going to
do I think I'm going to become Christian
bro it's up to you man it's up to you so
I just wanted to plant this seed for you
man I wanted to plant this seed for you
show you the truth and the revelation of
the
scriptures and show you that you can
know Christ
truly you can know his scripture
truly how do I do it then like is there
a process or is there
what to become
Christian oh it's it's simple this what
the Bible says I'll show you what the
Bible says and you I just got give you a
little something so this is Romans
chapter 10:9 because if you confess with
your mouth that Jesus is
Lord and believe in your heart that that
God raised him from the dead you will be
saved for with the heart One Believes
and is Justified and with the mouth one
confesses and is saved right for the
scripture says everyone who believes in
him will not be put to shame for there
is no distinction between Jew or Greek
for the same Lord is Lord of all
bestowing all the riches on all who call
on him for everyone who calls on the
name of the Lord will be saved so all
you have to do brother
if you're
genuine
um you truly believe that Jesus died for
your sins you truly believe that he is
the Lord of your life who took away your
sin who atoned for your sin and you
trust in him alone for your
salvation and you confess that you have
a mouth to confess it so you have the
ability to to confess it with your mouth
that God raised him from the dead
you're saved you're welcome into the
family of
Christ it's that
simple but only if you truly believe
this man it's it's it's you know you
don't want to do this if you're not if
that's not what you believe but if you
believe in the scripture and you believe
in God's revelation that's shown to you
you submit to the truth of the Gospel
you submit to it so if you want to do
this here you got witnesses you want to
do this here you can do it if you want
to do it in the comfort of your own home
do that there um
whatever say that again I'll do it I'll
do it you do it here praise the Lord
praise the Lord praise the lord well I
I'll just give you I'll just give you
something so um you denounce Islam as a
false
religion yeah you denounce Muhammad as a
prophet yeah
do you believe in your heart that Jesus
is
Lord yeah do you believe that he died
for your sins and rose again on the
third day yeah then welcome to the
family of Christ my brother you are now
a new creature you are now welcomed into
the family of Christ God says that all
who come and to believe in the son he
gives them right to be called sons of
God you're no longer just a slave you
are a son of God now in the family of
the Lord
The Next
Step this is what the Lord tells us to
do the Lord tells us to go and get
baptized to be baptized in the name of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
to be baptized to be submerged into
water which reflects you dying and being
buried like how Christ was buried risen
up again from the water showing that
you're being raised back to life just
like how Christ was raised to life so
immediately whenever you can go get
baptized in the name of the father Son
and Holy Spirit my
brother whenever you
can guys we have a new member in the
family of Christ glory be to God man the
angels are rejoicing do you have a Bible
with you bro you have a Bible at home or
anything I have one of the new test I
don't have the Old Testament but I have
one of the New
Testament okay that's cool well well you
got you got online too so you have
access to a Bible thank God for the
internet but we have we have access to
the Bible bro you can um message me on
on Instagram or anything do you use
Instagram I have an account I I don't
use it much but I have it yeah well okay
um what what what do you use um I do you
have Discord I do I do have Discord I do
have Discord yeah yeah I have Discord
okay um if somebody can put my Discord
Link in the chat
so that we we can see it put my Discord
Link in the chat man what a glorious day
we have brothers and sisters bro and in
my Discord link that um you know that
can help you with any questions that you
have or um because you you talked about
you you know Orthodox and Catholicism
got a lot of brothers in both that'll
educate you on that and you know however
God leads you you know you can make your
decision um
but you know just make sure you get
founded in the Bible right you got you
got to read the gospel learn about
Christ everybody's everybody's going
crazy in the comment section right now
they're rejoicing over you bro they're
Rejoice how long were you
Muslim I mean I I haven't really looked
into it much I mean I'm not like I don't
know how to say I'm I'm not that smart
on it so like I I claim to be but like
probably for m month or so because I
haven't looked into
religion okay so you haven't looked that
deeply into all of these things but then
the Lord brought you here and showed you
the Prophecies of the of the Messiah be
long before you can get brainwashed into
Islam glory to God man it's actually
really
good it's actually really good so guys
Rejoice for this brother Rejoice for
this brother man God led him to the
stream God shown truth and he submitted
to it man praise God praise God read the
gospel brother read um read Matthew Mark
Luke and John bro and uh that's where
you're going to learn a lot about Jesus
and what he taught how he acted what he
did that's where you're going to see the
character of Christ and I promise you
you're going to see that there is nobody
like him nobody that can compare to him
not a single person that walked this
Earth can compare to him not Muhammad
not Buddha
not Martin Luther King Jr
nobody
nobody but praise God for you bro but
yeah um guys did you put the Discord
Link in my in the comment
section put the Discord Link in my in
the comment section
guys uh which book should I read
first I would say uh Matthew start in
Matthew okay start start in the Book of
Matthew and and then just continue
reading
start in the Book of Matthew and just
continue reading Matthew Mark Luke John
okay thank you of course bro man glory
to God for this guy guys make sure you
guys hit the like button man a so
another Soul has been saved and brought
into the kingdom of God long before
Satan can get his hands on him
fully and um man just it's a glorious
day it's an absolute glorious day proess
and believer can you can you uh can you
post it again please I I don't see it
post post it one more time I joined it
oh you joined it okay I think
so okay man these comments are going so
fast all right thank you man all right
yeah so join the Discord you can hit me
up there um I'm I'm not that active I'm
not gonna lie to you but because of this
I will be more active and pay more
attention to it so if you have any
questions or anything like that just
just hit me all right okay thank you all
right God bless you bro take care of
yourself you too thank
you
wow Eric
Ben if you're still watching this it's
gonna be you next Lord
willing Lord willing the Bible says
today choose who you will serve today
don't
wait when you re when your ears
recognize the truth
when your ears and your heart recognize
the truth take hold of it do not wa oh
my godic